as far as the pressure thing or the
pressure question um
i don't think anyone will put more
pressure on myself than than me um i
have high exposure i high expectations
for myself on my whole
myself to a certain standard so coming
out each and every day and performing at
a high level um is is where the standard
is and of course yes desean played at a
very high level and has played at a very
high level uh throughout this
uh throughout his career uh i've been a
fan of his and i know him personally
but the opportunity
um
to be able to start here is something
that i that i look forward to and um
looking forward like i said just going
out and competing with
the guys that we have in our locker room
with great talent brandon cooks uh
randall cobb jordan akins
david johnson phillip linsley
mark ingram all guys that i've admired
from afar um being able to to be in the
locker room with those guys and to go
battle with those guys on sundays is
something that i'm looking forward to
that's tyrod taylor who will be the
starting quarterback in houston assuming
desean watson doesn't show up and he's
ready to go and peter you know this is
this is something that continues to loom
over the nfl but with aaron rodgers and
julio jones we don't talk about it much
desean watson what do you think is going
to happen
i think desean watson will begin the
year either on the commissioner's exempt
list or suspended by the nfl
because
i i would doubt that these cases would
be adjudicated
by the first week of september but you
asked me my gut feeling i think
you know you asked and that is my gut
feeling because to me i think one of the
big things is
you know i think deshaun watson if he's
being advised correctly he's got to if i
were advising him i'd say look at 2022
2022 is what really matters for you this
is going to be a disaster this season
this year is going to be a disaster your
whole goal in life has to be to be on
the field as some team's quarterback on
september 1 2022.
trial at some point will happen after
may of 2022 he can't be questioned under
oath until after this year's super bowl
which does create a window for him to
play
i think there's still a chance these
cases settle as i've said before you
don't get to the point where you're
haggling over whether or not the terms
of the settlement will be confidential
if you don't already have terms of the
settlement in mind there's no point
arguing whether or not we're going to go
public with all this and be allowed to
talk about it if you haven't reached the
consensus peter i think they have a
number that is palatable for both sides
and it it's just a matter of reaching an
agreement on the other terms and that
could happen at any time and if it does
all of a sudden desean watson's back in
play subject to his suspension i think
he still gets suspended but after that
suspension four six eight games he could
be playing for somebody other than the
texans that could make things very
interesting
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports